hey what's going on it's bill Barone
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
from Monday December 23rd 2019 what's
going on how's it going with you guys
how are you feeling how was your weekend
how have you been since Thursday
oh I've been [ __ ] great I passed my
test does that mean you have an
inspiration ever curating no it doesn't
it's the first that's the beginning you
got to pass a test and then there's then
you sit down before you check ride and
they give you basically a question and
answer thing the oral exam and then then
you have to go out and go fly via your
instruments only so but I guess the
hardest part is passing this thing so
Jesus and what a [ __ ] test holy holy
holy Toledo I went over to go take the
friggin test I woke up that morning I
was in the best mood I was like God
thank God I'm finally taking this test
I've been studying for four months
September October November December yeah
four months and I was just like I
haven't played drums in like three weeks
I have been watching football I just cut
everything out of my life other than my
wife and kid you know did less standup
I was like I have to [ __ ] pass this
thing so my teacher was like I call him
up I said do it I'm ready
I can I finally I can figure out the H s
eyes I can do I can figure out the tear
drop parallel direct I can tie I
understand the RMI I know all the
weather I know all the [ __ ]
regulations I can read the stupid
low-altitude [ __ ] charts and all of
this [ __ ]
so he goes fine well let's take it
either Thursday or Friday and I was like
what it goes yeah so my guard fine so
the day of the test Friday I wake up and
I'm just in the best mood and I'm like
I'm gonna [ __ ] pass this thing and
I'm not like you
no cramming of what I like Thursday I'm
not gonna lie to you Thursday I sat down
at one o'clock and studied until 10:00
other than you know making my wife and
kids some dinner or whatever and putting
my daughter to bed I was just doing that
and it was weird there was one part of
the HSI where I completely 100%
understood it and then there was this
other section where I didn't understand
it I just didn't get there was some
about that one involved the two front
flag or something for the for whatever
reason the first chunk didn't didn't
even have a two-front flag
I don't know this means anything to you
but I know there's a few pilots
whistling so anyway that part I don't
know but I just looked at the questions
enough times that if they [ __ ] ask me
something I think I could fake my way
through it or whatever I was like there
maybe this will be too two questions so
there's like on the book there's like a
thousand [ __ ] questions let's say and
out of those thousands they take [ __ ]
60 all right and you have to get at
least 70% so 7 times 6 is 42 right out
of 60 so that made my goal [ __ ] that's a
lot that I can get wrong three wrong out
of every 10 and get 18 wrong so I was
trying to psych myself up so the next
morning I wake up I'm just in the best
mood and I'll say time away from me I'm
gonna [ __ ] pass this thing it's gonna
be over then I'm gonna go to Vegas this
will all be off my [ __ ] head I can go
smoke a cigar and just [ __ ] relax
luck be a lady tonight Oh [ __ ] fresh
goals is alright he passed the test and
now he's challenged some goddamn dick
jokes luck be a freckles tonight right
so I I go over to my teachers house he
gives the stamp of approval when it goes
alright and I go and he goes you know
just to let you know he goes if you mess
this up you can go right back and take
it and you only have to kind of answer
the ones that you [ __ ] up but you only
have like five days because the end of
the year the whole thing changes you got
to take
over again so I'm like alright that's
pretty forgiving and then he goes up to
call up and every place was filled up
because it was a bunch of jackasses like
me trying to get in there take the
[ __ ] test before the whole thing
changes and you got to get a new book
and then go through all of that [ __ ]
crap all over again
so he ended up calling this other you
know the last [ __ ] place they had a
spot and it was like 11:30 he was yeah
it were open from 12 to 2 that's all we
got left and the test is like an hour
and 50 minutes long so I [ __ ] race
over there and you know I get there a
few minutes early right before 12:00 and
I'm [ __ ] looking at my you know now
I'm looking at the book or whatever I'm
gonna I got this dude I [ __ ] got this
and then I go in there I got my little
he's 6b and all the [ __ ] because all
right sign in everything's good you know
this is you yes it is Bubba bail this
government legal [ __ ] and I go upstairs
you go into this little [ __ ] room
there's a little computer and you just
sit there and there's a camera on you
making sure that you don't [ __ ] cheat
or anything and now I'm getting [ __ ]
nervous I'm sitting like I'll I got
[ __ ] [ __ ] much what if I blow this
well yeah [ __ ] whatever so I sit down
guy shows me I do it and and he like
clicks on a couple example two questions
and the first two he clicked on is like
I know both of those and I know the
answers and I could answer those in
about [ __ ] 8 seconds however long it
takes me to move that [ __ ] mouse
right and he leaves the room so I sit
down and I go to reach for the mouse and
my hand was like shaking a little bit
like right before the right before I get
ready to like you know back in the day
if I was gonna do you know stand up on a
talk show you know I always get like the
[ __ ] that that nervous thing where I
was just like it's a weird cut like
you're excited like I'm gonna [ __ ] do
this I know it's gonna go well and that
there's but I always had that thing
right before I went like let's just
[ __ ] go you know like what it's
what's-his-face and stayed at Grace
let's go that's always been my thing
I've never been nervous while it's going
on but waiting to go up like let's
[ __ ] go color you know
you're gonna wave to the host or that
stay that's alright let's go let's go
let's go let me get out there and see
what its gonna be
so anyway so I first to I take first two
questions Bam Bam right and I'm like oh
my god
I'm gonna [ __ ] it aces thing and then
the third question I'm like what in the
[ __ ] is this
I have no dye I don't know so I I
skipped that one then another couple go
alright then what the [ __ ] is this next
question what the [ __ ] is that alright
and then there was just too many of
those and I was like holy [ __ ] am I
gonna flunk this I might have [ __ ]
that I tell my podcast listeners I was
gonna take this that's not laughs tell
them that I [ __ ] Oh Billie failed
freckle-faced I'm gonna have to [ __ ]
tell him that come Monday so what I did
was I was like alright dude you need to
get your [ __ ] together alright if you
don't understand thing something just
skip it go on to the next one let's get
some [ __ ] hits here so we're feeling
[ __ ] good so I went through the whole
[ __ ] test and in the end I had like I
had like nine or ten that I didn't
answer and I just slowly worked my way
back through those things and you know
there was a thang couple of things on
the internet where I watched especially
with the HS I looked these at these
videos and that's they were just like
listen do you want to understand these
you just want to memorize them because a
lot of the questions you know in the
book are like almost verbatim on the
test what you think and I well that's
[ __ ] pretty easy but it's like now do
this like but there's so much [ __ ]
information in so many [ __ ] questions
it's only a little bit of an advantage
so anyway because people put videos like
that up there these people who give the
test got wise to that so not only did do
they switch up the questions from what's
in the book they then take right answers
from other questions and stick them in
there as a possible answer because a few
of them I would click on it and see this
answer like I know that's that
the right answer from and then I'd read
the question going that's not the
question or is it because at that point
you know your [ __ ] heads spinning and
it was that kind of my god right so
anyway when they told me an hour and
fifty minutes I'm like I'm gonna be
through this [ __ ] thinking about
twenty minutes who the [ __ ] needs an
hour and 15 minutes so an hour and ten
minutes later [ __ ] taking this thing
I finally finish it and a lot of times I
sat down I read a question I went out
you [ __ ] [ __ ] really [ __ ] [ __ ]
wasn't in the [ __ ] book I [ __ ]
whispered and then I'm like okay dude
you got a camera on your right now let's
not flip out too much maybe some other
technicality they can [ __ ] try to get
rid of ya you know funky on so I
finished the [ __ ] test and then you
bring the mouse down it's gonna tell you
immediately if you pass to fail and it
said finished and I said sounds like I'm
not going back through 60 [ __ ]
questions and doing this to myself [ __ ]
this I even know what I don't and I
clicked on it and it said you know are
you sure you're finished I click on
again and it's like are you sure you're
sure that you're finished and I click on
it again alright and then the screen
goes blank and I'm sitting there [ __ ]
heartbeat googa googa googa googa
and then the screen pops up and it goes
would you like to take a survey and I'm
like oh my god
what if I say no well they flunk me some
like yes I'd love to take a survey how
is the staff were they professional how
did you feel the test like great great
awesome you guys are perfect and then I
hit done when the screen goes blank and
I'm like how Jesus Christ out Jesus
Christ
my teachers gonna be so disappointed in
me oh my god all my listeners gonna
think I'm a [ __ ] moral and then it
[ __ ] came up 82% past I would have
liked to have done better and then it
was like you know you know when I hit
when I saw that I passed
I wasn't even relieved I didn't even go
like wow or anything like that I was so
[ __ ] fried you know from the last
like ten days where I was studying like
almost eight hours a day or whatever
and and just taking the [ __ ] test it
was like do you want to look at the ones
you got wrong and I was like yes and I
clicked on that and I just reviewed of
them reviewed them and I got like
through four of them and I'm like what
the [ __ ] am i doing I passed [ __ ] this
[ __ ] I just want to go to Vegas so I
went downstairs and the guy came up you
know got me out of the thing and then I
went downstairs and he goes this is the
piece of paper now that you have this
piece of paper though you can't get
another copy of this if you lose this
you need to present this you know to the
guy in your checkride to prove that you
passed the test if you lose this you
can't get another one and you know
you're gonna have to take the test all
over again so that [ __ ] thing I've
been looking at like fifty-eight [ __ ]
times and it wasn't until I drove out of
the place I drove out of the place that
all of a sudden it just [ __ ] hit me
and I just drove away like drove out of
there absolutely [ __ ] elated and then
I text a couple of guys that I've got
that taught me how to fly a helicopter
way back in the day four or five years
ago and they both flipped out and we're
super excited for me and they go dude
that's [ __ ] huge that's a major
accomplishment and they were both like
if I sat down and had to take that test
right now I don't think I could pass it
because there's a bunch of [ __ ] in there
that I guess you never [ __ ] use again
but they making no all of this stuff
it's just trying to weed out jerk-offs
that aren't taking it seriously or
[ __ ] morons or whatever but then
again I passed it so how good is the
weed out process so anyway old freckles
is a third of the way there so I have a
pretty now once you pass the test you
then have two years to take your check
right or I'll still have to take the
test all over again so I have a really
busy January and I'm gonna fly a little
bit then but then starting in February
I'm just going to
hardcore with this [ __ ] thing and fly
like three times a [ __ ] week get this
[ __ ] down while everything's fresh in my
head and then I'm gonna [ __ ] pass
this goddamn thing but uh I was very
excited because there's a number of
pilots that I know that are just [ __ ]
amazing and they are like and they were
really like going like that's like it's
so great that you're getting this thing
it's you know I don't know it's a hard
thing to explain if you don't fly or
whatever but it's just like I remember
one time one of the guys that I flew
with like I was talking about my
knowledge of helicopters and he laughed
and goes congratulations you know the
bare minimum to be up here because I had
a private pilot's license and I was just
like you know I don't want to be the guy
that knows the [ __ ] bare minimum so
there's like safety courses that you can
take for robinson's they have them down
and the [ __ ] is it then another on my
head still spreading from the thing for
next on Long Beach whatever the [ __ ]
that Airport is they got him right down
there I want to do that and that but I
wanted to get my [ __ ] instrument and
it was basically when I was in New York
unfortunately this guy got involved in
some weather in a helicopter and crashed
basically right across from where I was
staying and I was in the apartment when
it happened was weird I was walking out
the door I think Ray's a guy hit and I
didn't even hear it I was on a lower
floor that was unlike the you know
seventh or eighth floor and this
happened at the top of a building right
diagonally across which I believe is the
same building that that caroline's is in
and I was staying you know when I was
doing Pete Davidson's movie and I don't
know like I just was reading about that
story and like you know there was just
weather coming in and you know I don't
know what the [ __ ] happened but I know
it was like instrument IFR flight type
weather and like that [ __ ] has always
like haunted me in the back of my head
like like this time of year out here in
LA like last night I was looking up and
the clouds I mean yeah I don't know what
they were I don't know look they're like
[ __ ] 20,000 feet up in the air 30,000
feet probably even higher I don't know
I'm not good at judging that I don't fly
anywhere near that level right and like
an hour later I
came out I was taking my daughter to the
grocery store and I looked up and it was
just like they were at like 4,000 feet
this whole layer of clouds and the
entire city was just covered in clouds
and you know that's one of those things
you think like what if what if you were
flying around at 5,000 feet you know
north of here and then all of a sudden
you came back and where you were gonna
land everything's covered or whatever
it's [ __ ] scary so anyway now having
said that I fly in LA in like 99% of the
times it's just [ __ ] you're the only
thing you're dealing with this [ __ ]
haze or whatever so I know I know I
talked a lot about this [ __ ] but it was
a [ __ ] psyched you know I'm an old
guy you still be out there [ __ ]
taking tests and [ __ ] like that
hilarious and I'm really glad that I
took up this [ __ ] hobby because had I
not the last test I ever took would have
been in the early 90s when I was in
college and then they just walk around
like I know the stuff that I know and
now that's it for the next [ __ ]
god-willing 60 years of my [ __ ] life
I'm just gonna walk around and the last
thing I learned would be in like the
early 90s and then all of a sudden you
get on Twitter in the 2030s and you say
something that was fine in the early 90s
and then he gave that's how it goes down
man so yeah I took my daughter a
beautiful lovely daughter who just keeps
getting more gorgeous every single day
she's such a freak friggin cutie pie and
but here's something I noticed about
myself was that I've been really scared
to take her places I just get like I
can't even [ __ ] tell you I mean
unless you're a parent you like just the
scenarios that run through your [ __ ]
head the entire time you know what I
mean I put her in the car seat and I'm
just like make sure that thing's like
all the way up you know not across your
belly the thing that goes across the
seatbelt make sure that's up by your
chest make sure this is all tight you
know the hands 10 and 2 driving down the
friggin straight then you get to the
grocery store parking lot you get in or
out of the car you're like the emergency
brake
on what if some lunatic comes running
over and tries to grab her you know I
got my keys I'll [ __ ] stick it in his
[ __ ] jugular
then you know I'm walking through the
parking lot head on a swivel looking for
lino somebody some idiot to come back
and out somebody to drive too [ __ ]
fast and I just end up getting freaked
out and I just pick her up and I just
walk briskly over to the grocery cart
area and then I'm inside and I feel more
comfortable again I'm Tony the first
time I ever took my my kid outside when
she was maybe like six weeks old and I
was over the fact that she was
immediately gonna get catch some sort of
[ __ ] disease if she went outside and
breathed the la air like there wasn't la
air in my house the second I walked out
on my back porch my first thought was
what if a bird of prey came swooping
down and tried to rip her out of my arms
and I had played out this whole scenario
in my head where I threw her down
throw her believe it or not because it's
a bird of prey it was coming and quick
it was a perfect shot sort of like a
finger roll like Georgie Iceman Gervin
right and she landed right on the the
pillows on the couch and then I turn
around and I [ __ ] grab the bird by
both legs twisted one of his legs off
like when an alligator grabs you by the
arm it just does that death roll right
twisted it off and then turned it around
and stabbed the thing to death with its
own [ __ ] talents and that all went
through my [ __ ] head in like 0.5
seconds as I'm with my kid going like
would you little Q yeah yeah and in my
head I'm thinking of stabbing an eagle
to death with its own foot and I like to
think I'm a patriotic guy and that bird
is the symbol of our own country and
there I was stabbing it to that
endangered species to death to save
another human being even though I
repeatedly state that there's too too
many human beings but that's my human
being man so there's a difference anyway
I am so [ __ ] relieved
that that test is behind me and I'm
toying with the I've been looking at
some used helicopters on online because
of the amount of money that it's
actually gonna cost me because I have to
if I rent a helicopter because I have to
have one that has the gauges so I can go
up there and fly instrument flight rules
IFR and just the amount of money that
that's gonna cost but it's like or I
could just take that money and put it on
a down payment for something and then I
could fly whenever the [ __ ] I wanted to
and that would actually be a lot safer
because I wouldn't have to worry about
availability and I could fly whenever
the [ __ ] I wanted and my instructor
who's teaching me instrument is the of
all the great pilots I've flown with
this guy's the sickest pilot ever flown
with my life and I've gotten so much
better at flying because of flying with
him I could then fly whenever the [ __ ] I
wanted and I could fly with him and then
all of a sudden your brain just starts
going right so I've been looking at some
things you know I don't know I'm an I'm
a lunatic once I get into [ __ ] I just
get into [ __ ] and now like I [ __ ]
it's just another thing that I do I go
on YouTube i watch drum videos i watch
old sports and now i watch like aviation
videos and i'm trying to watch more
where i learned [ __ ] rather than
watching somebody how they died which is
unfortunately a very sad morbid way to
learn how not to get yourself [ __ ]
killed alright enough with the [ __ ]
aviation bill let's talk a little bit of
sports here how about yellow some NFL
football what who actually had time to
watch two whole games two whole [ __ ]
games I had time to watch because I
wasn't having my stupid freckled
adorable nose I'll say I have a cute
nose I got I got a cute nose for it for
an adult that's a pretty cute nose in a
book I watched your New England Patriots
against the Buffalo Bills and the
Buffalo Bills trying to turn it around
what a gay man it was a great game it's
the best game the Patriots played all
year again
a legit squad and the Buffalo Bills are
a [ __ ] legit squad and their
quarterback what's-his-name Josh Allen
I'll probably [ __ ] up the names
I got a kid now so I don't have time for
all of that [ __ ] football reference
scanning although I wish I did
beyond impressed with that guy how well
he throws his mobility in the pocket and
just I don't know in Buffalo's defense
they have a legit squad and you know
Brady's like what 42 43 years old so I
don't know how many you know a best-case
scenario I think he's got two seasons
left and at that point Buffalo's QB will
have like what four years of NFL
experience and then I think it goes back
to Buffalo which is really interesting
to me because before all this [ __ ]
started buffalo dominated the the AFC
East so this time they you know they
come through and my cousin's coaching
them and maybe he can push them through
and they can finally get their first
Super Bowl title they have to do it man
they got to do the people that went
through that [ __ ] that was in my early
20s when that all started I was 22 the
first note was 21 the first time they
lost that are 22 21 or 22 depending if
the Super Bowl was in January of 1991
the first time the bills you know the
wide right game which is still [ __ ]
ridiculous I mean the [ __ ] guy it was
a 48-yard I'm it's it's that's not
that's not like a chip shot
it just didn't [ __ ] curve back in
right but if somebody was in that early
20s then like me you're now in your
early 50s so anybody in their 30s and
40s at this point
back then I can't [ __ ] believe it is
now in their early 60s or early 70s and
they sat through watching them lose to
Super Bowl for [ __ ] years in a row
they can't have those people die off
like
when Brady retires I'm actually you know
I'm always a Patriots fan first but like
I don't wish that kind of misery on
anybody you know what I mean
so I will definitely you know if we go
you know if we totally suck or whatever
in the bills win the east and they go
into the playoffs I will definitely be
rooting for them because because they
lost four Super Bowls in a [ __ ] row I
thought you know I thought our defense
as always look [ __ ] great you know on
our offense was I don't know we had a I
thought we for the best running and
passing attack the balance of that that
we've had all year and this is like that
like that was one of those games that we
usually have in November and I get
excited like okay they tighten it down
the screws we're getting ready to do
another run but I would never put you
know I would never bet against Brady of
Belichick so we shall see but this is
definitely going to be tough because I
still think like you know despite all
our experience and all that type of [ __ ]
I just think we lost too many key people
and I don't know it just I don't know
it's gonna be real tough to try to get
passed ball tomorrow am i as a fan I
will hope but my head is so I'm sticking
with it I'm saying Seattle's gonna win
the whole thing they're gonna beat the
[ __ ] Ravens although that Lamar
Jackson is something else so who knows
who knows we shall see it's gonna be
[ __ ] fun it's gonna be a fun [ __ ]
playoff thing and next week my the game
of the week has got to be the Seattle
Seahawks against the San Francisco 49ers
who are letting up a ton of [ __ ]
points lately I would not be excited if
I was some hippy in San Francisco with
you [ __ ] you know here Birkenstock
zone I wouldn't be too [ __ ] thrilled
with what the hell they're doing they
need to fix that before they go into the
goddamn playoff sorry let me do let me
do a little bit of Reed's here alright
Oh simply safe everybody I only have one
read here
I own one read all right simply safe hey
evidently I just wanted to remind my
listeners time is running out on simply
safes huge holiday offer it's their
biggest sale of the year all right if
you're looking to fully protect your
home with award-winning 24/7 home
security now is the time to do it
burglaries spiked during the holiday
season with families traveling and
leaving empty homes and expensive gifts
behind your simply safes Holiday Sale
couldn't come at a better time look you
know Jesus Christ criminals what is the
Karma after you do something like that
simply safe has everything you need to
protect your home and family there's a
smart lock and video doorbell Pro to
defend your family a front door an army
of sensors and cameras that guards every
window door and roam in your home if
there's a break-in they can give real
time video confirmation to police as it
happens so police respond up to 3.5
times faster no surprise simply safe has
one CNET and pc magazine editor choice
awards simply safe made a holiday
oftener offer sorry for my listen with
my listeners in mind but it ends
December 31st you gotta get it done they
rarely do big deals like this so now's
your chance
visit simply safecom slash burrow find
out just how much you'll save and
remember this sale ends December 31st go
to simply save dot-com slash birth today
all right oh so the next day I get up
early to go to Vegas why did I get up
early because I'm working with Dean
Delray and the last time I worked with
Dean Delray in Vegas he went and he went
to this racetrack and he drove all of
these [ __ ] supercars around the
racetrack and everything right so he
said boy you got to do it you got to do
it I was just like you know it's
September I was like I gotta study for
this [ __ ] exam right so I was [ __ ]
doing that [ __ ] so this time around that
was another thing was in my head when I
was taking the test I was like Jesus
Christ if I flunk this [ __ ] thing am
I really going to go around and drive
these cars when I'll now only have
[ __ ] you know until December 31st to
take
this [ __ ] test again unfortunately I
passed it so I took like a [ __ ] you
know I don't know what 8:30 a.m. flight
out to Vegas you know got up early I was
so excited from passing the test you
know I couldn't get to sleep until like
1:00 in the morning and the night before
I couldn't sleep because I was nervous
about taking the [ __ ] test and then I
finally got to sleep and the [ __ ]
battery died in my smoke detector so I
started going babe babe every 30 seconds
babe and I'm like oh [ __ ]
so I had to get up and [ __ ] change
that goddamn thing in the middle of the
night so I was already wiped out tonight
before I had to woke up woke up early
and then so now we're going over to the
track to drive these cars and I can't I
can't tell you how not even into it I
was I was just like I don't give a [ __ ]
about I just want to go home and sleep
why am i [ __ ] doing this I should go
to sleep be all [ __ ] rest out rested
up you know we go over there I see the
cars I don't give a [ __ ] I'm a sedan guy
I don't like driving fast I'm old I like
smoking a cigar I like driving my old
[ __ ] pickup truck you know I Drive a
four-door sedan like that's just my [ __ ]
right I don't give a [ __ ] alright going
fast that's for [ __ ] young people in
there James Dean time of their life
right I'm that guy driving on Roger
Christ I got a kid in my car right so we
all the way we went all the way through
like the guy brings us in to give us
like the tests and I'm looking at this
he's got this line drawn all around the
track and I'm like alright the Reds got
to be where you're breaking the green is
where you're going really fast I didn't
understand it was actually there was red
white and green and like he's going
you're gonna be hard on the brake so
you're not gonna think that you can step
too hard we got a step super hard on the
brakes and then there's a point where
you're going through when you slow down
you get like this speed you want and he
goes you don't think these cars gonna be
able to take the turn I think but
they're going to be able to and there's
this point when you go through the turn
that you don't have your foot on the gas
or the brake which I thought in racing
you were either doing one or the other
you're letting the weight of the
are you going right through the turn and
then words green as you're coming back
on the throttle again and that was the
first time it perked up I was like wow I
never knew that and but I was still
tired of [ __ ] going like it's as amazing
as this is I would rather be laying with
the lights out sleeping right now but I
got to tell you something the second we
got the second we got in those [ __ ]
cars dude it was the sickest [ __ ]
experience I've ever had in my life and
now that I become I've been a racing fan
in here for the last three four years
the level of respect that I have of
these [ __ ] people that drive on and
what it is physically on you you [ __ ]
brain whipping around inside your
[ __ ] skull as you're going around
those turns I went out now [ __ ] a
Porsche the GTS RS GT whatever the [ __ ]
it is Dane's good with all of that [ __ ]
I took one of those things out and then
I took out this brand new Ferrari that
they have I forget which one it was but
it's the one where there's like a front
bumper and then behind the bumper
there's a there's like this cutout for
the air to come up from under the car
and then roll over the top of the car I
don't know what the thing was but both
of those cars were was as sick as the
Porsche was the Ferrari was unbelievable
the level of pike twice I didn't make
the first turn because I came down the
straightaway so fast and I kept thinking
if I stomped on the brakes like with a
normal car they was gonna lock up and I
was gonna spin out and and I also
learned by the end of it that you just
thought like you were impressing the guy
you were driving with it if he just for
stomping on the gas and all of that and
it's that's not what it is in like I was
really fighting the car and herky-jerky
the whole way around the track it's like
oh this is supposed to be as loud and as
crazy as this is this is supposed to be
smooth and the smoother it is and the
more you have to [ __ ] overcorrect
this is all obvious [ __ ] but as you're
doing it you don't realize it because
you're just thinking I want to go fast
that won't go fast right that you want
it to be this smooth just flow around
the whole track
the more you're doing that the better
you're like your lap time is going to be
and just literally the physics that were
involved and then the skill set that it
takes to do that just at a competent
level really blew me away and I have not
stopped thinking about it ever since and
I got to tell you right now if you're
one of these people you're listening
right now and you own a Ferrari or a
Lamborghini and you've never taken it to
a racetrack you're a [ __ ] idiot you
should be beating the [ __ ] out of that
car at a racetrack other than that what
are you just driving down the street
hoping a Prius doesn't t-bone you you
know pressing the button to raise the
[ __ ] the chassis up is you going over
speed bumps as the Dean was telling me
about a V buddy of his owns a
Lamborghini he has to do [ __ ] like that
it's a complete [ __ ] waste but if you
like if you buy one of those cars that
the only time that car should be on a
regular street is if it's on a trailer
on its way to a track and you should go
to a track and just beat the [ __ ] out of
it and the car will be happier that you
did it because that's what it's designed
for I cannot [ __ ] tell you I can't I
cannot I can't overstate how [ __ ]
exciting it was it was every time I go
to Vegas I'm gonna [ __ ] do that it's
a wrap and then the next thing you know
when I bought five laps in each car well
I can't I thought I bought five the guy
ended up hooking us up because he knew
Dean because Dean knows everybody right
so the next time I go there I would
suggest doing the way I did it the first
time get five laps in this five laps in
that because you're just like oh my god
I always want to drive this car I always
want to drive that car but the next time
you do it I would actually suggest
getting 10 laps in one car and do them
all in a row
and really work on trying to improve
like I forgot half the stuff he's okay
when you when you you know when you stop
it on the brakes like the weight is
those aren't these on the front of the
car
and then he has you come off the
throttle the brake or the throttle one
as you're going through the turn anybody
could come on the gas too too soon the
weights gonna be on the back of the car
and as you're turning your ass ends
gonna swing out like this [ __ ] I could
barely [ __ ] remember and I there's
actually a video that I posted on my
Instagram stories and me coming onto
this turn and I thought it was a cool
[ __ ] video because I come flying by
in that Ferrari and it sounds like you
know I'm in for adverse Ferrari and [ __ ]
but like the fifth it wasn't until the
fifth time I watched it that I looked at
my line coming out of the turn I was
like I'm way wide like that's [ __ ]
horrific and I really thought about it I
was just like wow that guy I was driving
with was probably thinking this guy
[ __ ] stinks he's fighting the car the
whole [ __ ] time but anyway it was
just I can't imagine to have to do that
seventy to a hundred [ __ ] times or in
stock car where they have like 200
[ __ ] laps in the entire time you're
dealing with the stress of trying to
have the best lap time every time you go
around the track meanwhile somebody
[ __ ] right on your ass you know bump
in India and all of that [ __ ] it's like
a whole new level of respect for that
[ __ ] I want to thank everybody down
there that hooked us up and put up with
my horrific driving dee drove great and
we just took out like street level cars
we'd even take out the race cars like
the next time I think I'll take out one
of the [ __ ] race cars but I was like
terrified of those things that's just
like dude I don't I don't drive fast
ever like on my car it's a supercharged
v6 and because of the weight it's more
than enough power for the weight of the
car it's more than enough power the only
time I really you know turn the knob so
like it's it's automatically things you
really got to stomp on the gas for the
supercharger to kick in or you can just
have it in that mode in the second you
hit it you're just gonna take off from
the line the only time I do that is when
I'm on a two-lane thing that's going
down to one lane and I want to get in
front of the person next to me
I just use it for that and then I put it
right back on grandpa mode whatever I'm
[ __ ] old what do you want from me
speaking of old I'll tell you what's
getting [ __ ] old right now is the the
Boston Bruins with this [ __ ] losing
streak let's look up like I can't
remember the last time they [ __ ] won
a game like we're on like a five-game
you know maybe we lost an overtime at
best and got one point but we have just
been losing losing losing losing the
last like I don't know what we lost to
the [ __ ] Islanders Johnny Boychuk man
there's a guy we never should have got
rid of all right here it is we lost to
the Avalanche on the seventh we lost to
Ottawa on the ninth we lost to the
Capitals on the 11th we lost the Tampa
Bay on the 12th all right we beat
Florida we lost to the Kings and
overtime we lost to the Islanders in a
shootout we lost to Nashville in
overtime so in the last 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
games we have lost oh my god we've lost
seven times once in all the time once in
a shootout so in the last like possible
like 14
oh sorry 16 points we've gotten three
points and now we got to play the
[ __ ] capitals Jesus Christ we got a
[ __ ] we got the Capitals the Sabres
home and home and then we got the Devils
to close out 2019 before we go into a
new decade so hopefully they're gonna
[ __ ] turn it around but I love this
Bruins team you know what who gives a
[ __ ] who gives a [ __ ] if it happens this
time of year you know maybe the Bruins
are looking a little forward through the
holidays they're excited to get a new
pair of skates or something for
Christmas I don't know what the [ __ ] it
is oh I didn't talk about the Eagles own
Cowboys what a huge win for the
the seven and seven Eagles against the
seven and seven Dallas Cowboys they had
like a bunch of injuries and [ __ ] so I
wish I wasn't aware of but I'll guess it
was a huge one you know it's [ __ ]
great as I love Troy Aikman you can as
much as he tries to be impartial when
the Cowboys are not playing well you can
just hear it in his voice like these
guys are dropping pastors they're not
getting it done like he almost he starts
to go back into the huddle you know
telling guys they got to start making
[ __ ] plays but then you know he's
always quick I'm sure Eagles fans think
a hundred percent but then again think
of some of the [ __ ] that you didn't said
to him which by the way how great was it
that when I Tom aswhat into the crowd
with those two stupid sixer fans giving
him the finger saying [ __ ] you [ __ ] and
he went in like a gentleman I hope he
didn't get fighter you know when the
[ __ ] that happened hopefully he didn't
get [ __ ] suspended or anything like
that and then whole [ __ ] idea that
you know you bought a ticket and you can
do and say whatever you want and that
these guys are just gonna have to
[ __ ] deal with it and it's on them to
be professionals i 100% disagree with
that 100% disagree with that I mean it's
very easy to get on a [ __ ] player
without crossing a line and then also
there's gonna be kids there in that type
of [ __ ] anyway so you shouldn't be out
there talking the way that I talk on
this podcast there you like that you
like the hypocritical aspects of that so
anyways look at the [ __ ] in the NBA
Louie God you got the [ __ ] 76ers so
they finally put together a team you
know LeBrons going out to [ __ ] LA and
you got the goddamn the surprising Heat
and I thought they way overpaid for
Kelly Olynyk despite the way that man
plays in a game seven you show me a guy
in the NBA right now with a better track
record in a Game seven
than Kelly Olynyk granted he only played
one game seven for the Boston Celtics
but I'll never forget it that goes that
goes down with all the great Celtics of
all-time
as far as somebody stepping up and at
Game seven and putting the [ __ ] team
on his back that guy did it
he [ __ ] did it you
no it was just kelly olynyk games 1
through 6 but game 7 he became something
else so ever since then I've always kind
of kept an eye on that guy and I'm
hoping that he play a game 7 how cool
would that be and if they played a game
7 and once again he was the guy and then
he just had this [ __ ] thing where he
was just kelly olynyk you know that said
he's a bad player but he's not he's not
a superstar player he's not on a star
level player right but you get that guy
in a game seven when it all counts and
all the chips are pushed in the middle
of the [ __ ] table and that
[ __ ] delivered so I am a huge
[ __ ] kelly olynyk fan it was also
because right when he did that I was
reading this great book on Bob Cousy and
Bill Russell which was also a history of
the NBA and the Boston Celtics all at
the same time cannot recommend that book
enough the only thing that sucks is Bill
Russell was not in the book with any
sort of a quote but Bob Cousy is all
over the book it would have been great
to hear bill Russell's perspective on a
lot of that stuff but I don't know so I
was reading about all the Celtics and
all these big games and all these great
games and I always always you know
Lakers would always come up short and
they would some Celtics always figure
out a way to win and then right as I was
reading that book Kelly Olynyk had that
game seven okay maybe the [ __ ] they
played but anyways out here in LA you
should see how [ __ ] catty the goddamn
LA Clippers are getting with the Lakers
which I don't know how that helps them
where they have all they have all this
[ __ ] where they look like they're just
talking about the Clippers but they're
clearly [ __ ] on the Lakers
there was one that it's it's we before
me we over me or something like let me
look these up it's all of it is just
like meow LA Clippers LA Clippers
advertisements billboards
see what they got here Jesus of course I
can't find any of but they all just like
are talking about how they're playing as
a team and there's no flash which is
clearly like a dig with like the
Showtime Lakers you know
Dyan Cannon and the crowd and all of
that type of [ __ ] but I will tell you as
a Boston Celtics fan first of all I love
the [ __ ] team we have this year I'm
[ __ ] loving it just didn't work out
with Kyrie Irving amazing [ __ ] player
it just didn't [ __ ] work out kambei
Walker is been amazing so far still my
favorite team since I started watching
them again was the Isiah Thomas led
Celtics you know with Jae Crowder and
[ __ ] Kelly Olynyk and all of those
[ __ ] guys I loved that team that team
was one of the toughest teams to beat in
the NBA and I still don't think we're
where that team was as far as just the
[ __ ] defense that those guys could
play and I was just never say die but
I'm loving with what the Celtics are
right now but having said that the
[ __ ] LA Lakers are scaring the [ __ ]
out of me and how seamlessly Davis has
fit into that team and accepting his
role that LeBron's LeBron and then
there's him and he's totally fine with
that that's the type of [ __ ] that leads
somewhere that I don't want the Lakers
to go but they they look great but I got
to tell you you know I've kind of let go
of you know like losing sleep and
seriously [ __ ] hating all these other
these you know my rivals and all of that
[ __ ]
I'm but it's right below the surface but
I just realize how stupid it was like
this run that Boston has gone on you
know the thing is you always want that
to happen and the payoff is that you'll
be a happy sports fan but if you still
like giving a [ __ ] and watching and like
I know what I want to want to give up
like I'll always hate the [ __ ] Lakers
I'll always hate the Canadiens
and whatnot but like I I have to in the
Yankee I just got to give up I just want
to not be that sports fan who then if my
team isn't even playing I'm sitting
there rooting against a franchise like
you know what that's like that there's
this whatever profession you're in like
if you have like a falling out with
somebody and then you just have to like
you know be in the same room with them
and then not talk to them like the
amount of [ __ ] energy that that takes
like I fortunately don't have any of
those relationships currently in my life
right now where I walk into a room you
know oh maybe I got a couple from way
back in the day I guess but even then I
a are you doing or whatever I don't give
a [ __ ] I just I don't give a [ __ ] in its
just to like I'm gonna [ __ ] 51 years
old I'm gonna [ __ ] sit there and act
like some chick in high school like oh
my god I like saying that fat kid
talking to you
I even have [ __ ] people that like I
haven't seen a long time ago I just had
a falling out with them and I stopped
talking to if I [ __ ] saw him today I
just say are you doing whatever could we
not to be friends or whatever who gives
a [ __ ] right the same thing is like a
sports fan like oh my god I am like so
not rooting for them and I'm just gonna
sit there [ __ ] like losing my [ __ ]
like I don't give up I gotta give a [ __ ]
about the Seattle Seahawks anymore I
give a [ __ ] about PKI guys so gave a
[ __ ] and then just one day it hit me I
like what am i doing you know I think
it's just having a kid I just want to be
that guy going I can scream at the
[ __ ] TV is my kid sitting at I can't
do it anymore so just because of that
and it's just it's made like more
enjoyable say why can't I just [ __ ]
enjoy the fact that Pete Carroll is a
great coach okay why does it bother me
that so many people on that team tested
positive for steroids and they never get
[ __ ] for cheating that he did that
little [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] and then the
training camp and if the Patriots did it
it'd be a [ __ ] huge scandal and
somewhere because suspended
longer than [ __ ] Ray Rice when he got
knocked I don't care [ __ ] I'm trying to
get rid of it anyway so let's uh let's
let's look at the let's look at some of
the reads here let's look at some of the
reads here it's early in the morning
here
I always make breakfast I love [ __ ]
cooking for my ladies all right
Christmas movies dear Billy silver balls
I like that one hanging out seeing the
girl you have a crush on too scared to
say hello cuz you have orange hair
[ __ ] freckles pasty skin looking like
Howdy Doody alright I don't I don't
recall hearing you mention your favorite
Christmas movies ever by the way if if I
just said hello all of that would have
worked out and I wouldn't become a
comedian I'm a Christmas carol fan
myself oh yeah I respect anybody who can
do anything musically anyway I think the
Muppet Christmas Carol is the funniest
most Christmassy spirited movie of the
season you know and I think I might look
that up on YouTube pay for it and watch
that with my wife tonight oh no we have
it we have a Christmas party I think
your your daughter would like it other
gems from my childhood and Clint include
the California California Raisins
claymation special I don't think I can
watch that with my wife and the
lesser-known Garfield Christmas we still
break it out our VHS copy every year
take us through some take us through
some of your favorites also do you have
Christmas pajamas I'm wearing them right
now
they say ho ho ho on the the pajama
bottoms take us through some an who
likes eggnog always has Christmas
pajamas that's nice police work sir or
ma'am merry Christmas to you and yours
Happy Hanukkah happy Kwanzaa go fudge
yourself he didn't say happy Kwanzaa but
if you got to go christmas and hanukkah
you got to throw Kwanzaa in there right
anyway my favorite ones yeah all of
those claymation ones I love Rudolph the
red-nosed reindeer and I loved it more
and more as I get older when you just
see like how unforgiving and what a bad
example Santa Claus is in that one he's
just like different get out of here we
don't need you you know and then all of
a sudden then they [ __ ] need him
there's a linkage there's a really great
life lesson in that one you know where
it's just like he was different he had a
red nose you know I had red hair so you
know I was like relating to this [ __ ]
guy and it's just like all right look at
this now now that the thing has to you
know go off and go hang out with all the
losses you know which was where I was
for a while you know before I started
being funny and making people like me
through that then I think you know all
of a sudden you know he's got the
[ __ ] red nose and [ __ ] I think Santa
Claus needs him again and then it's just
like I you know something and Rudolph
takes the job he doesn't cut off his red
nose to spite his face and that's like a
big [ __ ] thing I learned in this
business they were like club owners that
wouldn't book me or they said some bad
[ __ ] to me or whatever and I was like oh
someday someday boy oh boy I'm gonna be
funny and then you're gonna want to book
me and I'm gonna be like you know what
you said this and this and then I'm like
[ __ ] you and it's like that I don't you
want to book me now fine why would you
know that I was good I wasn't good when
you saw me you could only go with the
information that you had now I'm good
enough to play your club and you want a
book we saw I'm gonna take the [ __ ]
work why would I take the left [ __ ] you
have never [ __ ] playing there [ __ ]
festival cuz you never [ __ ] if you're a
young comic listener that is the biggest
dumbest stupidest [ __ ] waste of time
and it's bad business
take the gig and go in there and do a
great job and be a good guy and then you
know what the club owner will be nice to
you you know what you end up being
friends and then someday you get to bust
his balls anybody I never did that I
never say yeah you think you did I do it
to Jamie Masada at the Laugh Factory all
the time one of my great friends in this
business all the time I break his balls
all the time he's always like badi badi
why why you why you talk to me this way
buddy then I go cuz you [ __ ] you
banned me from your club I never did
that funny yes you did yes you did
because you had a little bit of power
over me and you were having a bad
[ __ ] week and I looked like a puppet
and you thought I was the guy he could
[ __ ] with and you did and as you can see
I let it go
he's [ __ ] hilarious he was like Billy
bar belly bar ladies and gentleman belly
bar ladies and gentlemen and gentlemen
belly bar when he [ __ ] calls me up
every [ __ ] time he sends me an email
and he writes said Barry bye ladies and
you have a ladies and gentlemen Billy
bar belly bar ladies and gentlemen one
of my favorite people in this business
Jamie Masada but there was a time in my
career where I was just genius engage
gonna well me with his club then tell me
why would I do that there's only three
comedy clubs out here stage time is so
[ __ ] different VIN wasn't if there
was a [ __ ] under clubs I would still
do it cuz it's a waste of [ __ ] energy
and that's what I get out of the Rudolph
the red-nosed reindeer okay even if you
look different you can still have
greatness in you and in the end when
those people who didn't understand you
welcome you back mainly because they
want something from you not because
they've turned over a new leaf you don't
waste your energy hating them and then
you hang out next thing you know you're
the [ __ ] lead Doug pulling the
goddamn sled alright and then the heat
miser one I love because people used to
always tease me telling me I look like
mr. heat miser when I was a kid and I
hated it
do you think I'd be on the school bus
and they'd all be seeing it
he miser Noby bills mr. heat miser I'd
be sitting there like shut up stop
saying that you know anyway so that was
those are some of my favorites I like
the Charlie Brown Christmas one and I
hate that we haven't watched any we'd
been watching a lot of Disney movies
though last night like last night I I
watched Peter Pan with my daughter and I
can't I never know I don't think I
really ever watched that movie when I
was a kid I didn't watch a lot of them I
cannot believe like what a self-involved
little [ __ ] [ __ ] that Peter Pan
is he's so [ __ ] self-involved it
reminds me of you know some people I've
met in this business like just like
full-on [ __ ] narcissist where it's
just like wow it's just really all about
him he sort of redeems himself in the
end when he has to save Tinkerbell and
stuff but like I was sitting there
watching it with nyan when he goes to
save Tinkerbell I looked over to her and
I was like you know that's the first
selfless thing this green little [ __ ]
has done this movie she goes oh yeah
he's he's horrible in this movie and I'm
gonna watch that when my daughter's a
little bit older and I'm just gonna be
like you know someday you're gonna meet
a guy like that alright and he's gonna
ask you out and you know if I've even
remotely done my job you're gonna laugh
in his face and say no don't ever
[ __ ] bring a guy home like Peter Pan
no Jesus that's starting already
I can't do that because then that's
exactly what the [ __ ] she's gonna bring
home alright date story from away
I recently went to a farmers market
where I met a woman who wanted to set me
up with her single never married a 40
year old son oh okay well is he crushing
it in the business world cuz I mean
maybe he just didn't have time for that
part of his life other than that I'm
already seeing a red flag anyways she
said I just been dumped a couple weeks
before so I figured why not I gave her
my I gave her my number and ended up
going on a dinner with him after the
male waiter took our order he turned to
me and said doesn't our waiter have a
great smile
the waiter was male and he never
completed my appearance at all okay well
I mean he could just be a guy that just
you know likes people okay now right now
you're acting like P so far with this
far into the story but you know how it
ends up I feel like you're leading me
down the road that this guy's gay and he
doesn't know it or he's in the closet or
he's fighting it or whatever but as of
right now he just made an innocent
comment about the waiter and he hasn't
talked about you and I just talked about
Peter Pan and that's fresh in my head so
right now I'm picturing you dressed all
in an all green dress all right when we
finished our dinner he offered to give
me a ride home we got to the parking lot
and there was his white 9 passenger van
oh my god okay I need to reevaluate my
life choices because I hopped right in
that car oh my god he walked me to my
door and I gave him an awkward side hug
and ran into my apartment good for you
the next day he texted me thank you for
joining me for yum-yum's and a cocktail
last night it's safe to say I went on a
date with a gay man right
no no it's it's safe to say that you
know why this guy is 40 years old and
single okay
joining me for some yum-yum's and a
cocktail last night is just I mean
that's just just something you read it
you have to walk it off that's like you
read he just go and then you have to
walk it off
yeah and he's got a 9 passenger van you
listen this guy might be a little odd
but I think it's I think he just I think
it's safe to say that you didn't vibe
with this guy he might just be one of
those those straight guys that just
exists in that weird [ __ ] area like
for any pilots listening right he's got
the teardrop entry into [ __ ]
heterosexuality you know you got you
John Wayne types all right you got you
betas and then you get those those the
straddle errs you know which is [ __ ]
hilarious especially right now where
everybody's supposed to be woke and
progressive and all that but then when
you meet somebody who's comfortable
enough to say that another man has a
nice smile and described food as
yum-yum's that they're immediately like
yeah you know women are repulsed by that
I just think that okay this guy could
still be straight but he's just he's one
of those guys that you know if an
intruder comes through the door he's
probably gonna be yelling louder than
you
screaming I should say you know not
saying that gay guys can't fight I would
never suggest that all right you know I
would never suggest that especially
after all the bear videos I've been
watching
and you know the nickname for like a
manly gay guy is a bear so like now if
if a [ __ ] I'm gonna tell you
something if a gay guy who's described
as a bear fights anywhere like a real
bear I wouldn't want to go out I would
want to be anywhere near one of those
guys when they get pissed off so I think
it's safe to say that you dated somebody
that made you really [ __ ]
uncomfortable and that your nether
regions were drier than the [ __ ]
Serengeti during the yeah you're not
gonna bang this guy all right yeah I can
bang this guy you're not gonna be with
this guy
it's [ __ ] over I mean the 9 passenger
van is he driving around on a company
car thank you for joining me for yum
Yum's in a cocktail last night I will go
my god I don't even know like I'm
actually gonna say that like I want to
say that the next time I go out get a
[ __ ] steak dinner with a buddy of mine
I'm gonna say that hey thank you for
joining me for some yum Yum's at a
cocktail like I can't do that I get all
[ __ ] I don't all right let's see yeah
let's walk that one off let's walk down
mm-hmm all right have you noticed that
though there's something like a gay guy
that's like out of the closet it's like
totally relaxed the something that's in
the closet is one of the most
uncomfortable things ever so if that
guy's in III understand like maybe that
was like the [ __ ] tone you're just
like oh my god just go blow somebody get
it over with so we just [ __ ] relax
you're out of the closet you just don't
know it just [ __ ] be gang so we can
all relax all right lay fan I got two
ladies here all right dear bill I'm a
big fan of your stand-up in the podcast
and a TC and what it does for the
performer so thank you very much I'm
glad you notice that one of the big
things that we take pride in is is is
being a place that comedians can come to
and not get [ __ ] over you know put out
a special or help out their podcast is
something that turns into ticket sales
or advertising whatever it's what we're
trying to do not say all right I enjoy
by the way Jessica Carson special
totally blew up so when she goes on the
road please go out and buy a ticket go
see her she's an absolute [ __ ] legit
monster [ __ ] headliner and it also
makes our company look great when people
like Paul virzi put out a special and
now he's legit headliner so I never get
to work with him on the road anymore I
cannot see I cannot wait to see what
Paul VARs he's gonna buy when he starts
making serious money I cannot I cannot
whatever it is I know it's gonna be
white he's got too much Sicilian in him
okay it's gonna be a white car a white
fur coat white leather furniture there's
gonna be something something with a
white Christmas tree that Ray Liotta
came home with and Goodfellas I'm
telling he's gonna do it and it's gonna
make my [ __ ] life to see him buy that
all right anyway I enjoyed the bi-weekly
dose of your advice and your humor on
the podcast you ask women to write in
and mention you sometimes need to dial
back the women bashing most of which is
just hilarious yeah I'm just [ __ ]
around come on but the rest of it I find
a percent belief I'll let you do the
math actually I think it's all hilarious
to be honest I do have a question about
you you were first slash reply to women
that you have exhibited over a period of
time what I do have a question about the
okay this is how it's written I do have
a question about the you refer a slash
reply to women that you have exhibited
over a period of time if anybody can
tell me what that means I am all ears
when you are responding to men reading
relationship advice
you constantly compliment them for
landing any kind of [ __ ] if it's a
young guy dating an older woman
he's a stud he gets to bang multiple
women he's a stud he knows how to chat
up and charm the ladies again and
some occasion you advise them to bang
women even if the situation is bad toxic
or the woman in question is [ __ ] up or
as issues do I I don't think I took it
that far it comes off as you in
summation is saying to these guys take
advantage of that [ __ ] up woman and
user is a jist toilet then get out of
there
I'll go [ __ ] yourself I can't stand that
[ __ ] perspective I am so sick of
women acting like when they're getting
banged like it like they're out they
have raking the leaves on your front
yard that whole [ __ ] attitude women
have where both people got laid yet they
still need like a gift bag when they
walk out the door like something good
didn't happen for them to like sex
doesn't feel good for them I am so
[ __ ] sick of them acting like they're
put upon to have sex with a guy if you
don't want to bang a guy don't bang the
guy but if you're getting banged you
decided that you wanted to get bang and
you [ __ ] and join it don't act like
you [ __ ] went out there and you know
cleaned out the gutters on the house you
got laid oh my god that drives me up the
[ __ ] it that's that's them in a [ __ ]
nutshell that they always got to play
the [ __ ] victim always oh they're
always the [ __ ] victim anyways
however you don't give women who write
in any stud props and compliments or
advice like that I don't think that's
true I have anyway there's no have a
good time riding that dick then dip out
on his ass woman's seem to only have a
place on a scale from beautiful
thoroughbred slash good girl which come
off as women who have taken a
respectable place is some man's
exclusive breathing fleshlight oh Jesus
Christ
did you just take a woman's Studies
class to bottom-feeder [ __ ] I know you
have your bits and all I get that but
this seems to be a little different do
you don't either brilliant so this is
how great women are with manipulation
how she's I'm big Fanny you stand up I
love the podcast ATC everything you do I
can listen to you bash women I and I
find all of it funny however and then
they get into their actual point that's
what they do they totally get you all
[ __ ] likes none of this [ __ ] all that
[ __ ] up front was total [ __ ] lip
service and then they go into this and
this is why I have the issues that I do
with one amongst other things with women
is that they can never just square up
their [ __ ] shoulders and just [ __ ]
come at you it's got to be this better I
like that they look at this a more the
other end does some [ __ ] shady [ __ ]
alright anyway uh what gives I got a no
just so you know the times I've heard
you call a [ __ ] a bottom-feeder [ __ ]
she actually sounds like a bottom-feeder
[ __ ] well then I don't know what you're
saying cuz now you're all but you're
buying it all back well I do what you do
I'm doing what you're doing all right
when you hear a story of a man and a
woman you put yourself into the story
and you picture yourself as the woman so
you get overly sensitive on that side
and I put myself in a story I look at
myself as the guy and I get overly
sensitive for the guy I mean not to the
point of describing food as yum Yum's
so that's basically what's going on I'm
just doing what you're doing all right
and that whole [ __ ] thing back in the
day how come if a guy does it he's a
stud how come if a woman does it she's a
[ __ ] is one of the easiest answered
questions ever it's the skill set
involved all right for a guy to get laid
it takes skill this is skill set
involved for a woman to get laid like a
woman's opening line in a bar could be
like hey do you want to [ __ ] me she's
gonna get laid if a guy walks in and
does that he's gonna get drinks poured
over his head he's gonna slapped in the
face he's gonna get cancelled on social
media there's no skill set involved
that's why
does that make sense you don't have to
come up with the [ __ ] opening lie
that I played this game on time with my
wife I said you know something let's
just she was bitching about all the dumb
guys say would say to her back in the
day or whatever when they tried to hit
on her and I was just like I you know
fair enough that is dumb [ __ ] but let's
just turn the tables let's let's you hit
on me you come up with a line that
dazzled me guys do this with you a woman
it's [ __ ] hilarious the lack of game
they have as bad as your game is you
wait to you hear that they have zero
game she was saying to me [ __ ] to me and
I was just laughing or I was just like
rolling my eyes or whatever and then she
she actually had the nerve to say to me
especially after all this [ __ ] she put
me through to she was going like see now
you just try to make it difficult it's
like yeah every guy's world so I don't
know I don't know what you're saying I
mean I'm actually at this point
questioning if you're even a fan I think
that that was all [ __ ] and you
probably actually don't like me I'm
actually thinking that you're you're the
guy you're with likes me and you [ __ ]
hate me so you wanted to make this point
and you wanted to get it on the podcast
so what you did was you threw a bunch of
sugar and [ __ ] syrup in the beginning
of it I don't believe any of that I
don't think you like me I think you
think I'm a [ __ ] misogynist and then
you just [ __ ] dressed it up like that
but I did answer your question that is
why and I also overcorrect during this
time where they act like only men are
predators and that men can never be
victims and that women cannot be
predators and you know which is just
simply not the [ __ ] case all right
you know I mean the amount of guys out
there who if you see who are successful
and then you see their wife I mean
successful guys regardless of what they
look like have these beautiful wives
okay and you know there's this [ __ ]
thing out there that you know a certain
level of woman does not [ __ ] with a
certain level guy until he reaches a
certain level of success I don't blame
him for it I mean why would they settle
for less when they can get something
more but don't act like there's not like
an agenda out there and then you see if
you take that formula and you got
somebody who's a [ __ ] sociopath total
[ __ ] narcissist you're gonna have a
guy who worked his ass off his whole
[ __ ] life to get somewhere and some
woman who didn't do [ __ ] other than have
her tits hanging out of the front of her
[ __ ] shirt he's gonna get his [ __ ]
house and that happens on a regular
basis and to sit there and act like
there wasn't some sort of predator
victim involved there and that my whole
perspective I mean granted the way
presented is misogynistic I could easily
dress that up the way that last you know
for you know to defer to just pretend
that you have feelings for somebody when
you really just have feelings for their
car and their bank account I mean I
could I could say it in a nicer [ __ ]
way but that's nothing you listening to
the wrong podcast all right all right
moving on
here we go missing booze found a
solution by accident hey Billy buy booze
buy buy booze yeah exactly exactly I'm
coming up on 400 days of no [ __ ]
booze and I don't know man I think I'm
done for good I also think when you take
this much time off and then all of a
sudden you go back I think people look
at you like weird and no matter what you
say like now I'm in control this time I
just have one I just have like maybe
I'll have a glass of wine with a with a
with a nice meal you know if it's an
event I'll have a glass of wine and
that's it I think always people after
you took a significant amount of time
off people just look alike Oh God how
soon before it goes off the rails which
to be honest the way I binge drink would
not be you wouldn't be wrong if you
looked at me like that anyway I'm a
married introverted teacher and my wife
loves people I used to take tiny bits of
adderall and drink booze to build up the
will to hang with her friends do you
realize what you're doing to your liver
long-term I'm telling you man like I
have such a newfound respect for sober
people that they just take life in the
face every [ __ ] day
I think what you have to do in those
situations sir is you have to find the
comedy in your shortcomings socially and
it's actually a way to kind of get
yourself out of it if you actually say
something stupid in those moments and
then call yourself out on it and just
make a joke about how bad you are
socially usually the person you're
talking to starts laughing if you do it
the right way just just don't do the
hip-stir tap out oh my god awkward just
don't do that and then put the whole
weight of the conversation on the other
person you just hold up your end of it
just going like I suck at this I'm
trying to get better at this if you just
say that you'll be fine and people will
help you out and it just it's it's like
it's this once again it's like the gay
thing out of the closet it's out there
everything's fine in the [ __ ] closet
it's everybody still [ __ ] knows and
then it's the big elephant in the room
and everybody's [ __ ] feeling weird
say that that analogy straight across
the [ __ ] board if you just awkward
socially address it and just be like I'm
but you know I'm gonna get better right
it just becomes funny and people will
help you out and it's usually so many
things in life you think are a [ __ ]
Mountain you have to walk up and it's
really you just have to step up onto a
curb it's really not that big a deal
it's just that it happened to you when
you were so young you know when your
world was so small that you don't have
like perspective and these little
[ __ ] things become these giant things
that you're looking up at and and it's
really not that big a deal alright so
come out of your shelf but I'll read the
rest of I had depression fatigue
hopelessness etc I've been there a
regular person wouldn't know know it and
I never wanted to admit it so
consequently I never tried to fix it
well that's what they got therapy for he
says anyway parenthesis with the S all
right anyway he wrote it correctly I'll
say it correctly I tried to find a
natural way to recreate the feeling of
my social vices I learned about
neurotransmitters dopamine serotonin I
don't know what this word is
asked a stack low clone
Cole I'm a sty a stile : a c ET y LC t y
LC i guess y axes like a vowel it's like
a Russian last name o li n : a sty : I
can spend the rest of my podcasting
career trying to figure out how to sound
that thing out I always feel like
purgatory if there is such a thing of
purgatory like that's what purgatory is
they'll be like alright pronounce this
word correctly once you do then you can
come in to heaven and then you spend
like half of eternity before you finally
get you by the time you finally get it
right you don't even give a [ __ ] in
coming at heaven you know and I don't
give a [ __ ]
alright turns out I lack I lack these
things it says - 5 - ATP for serotonin
50 milligrams three times a day for that
feeling of satisfaction you get after
drinking or smoking the first time after
a long day this is already making me
nervous that you're going this this like
pill route or whatever l ty-- Tyros in
and something else I can't even read
I've fin I'll lay la lalala lalala 9 I
swear to God pH e NY la la this la la la
la 9x9 la la 9 for motivation and energy
alpha GPC or a CDP 4 : for focus and
clearing brain fog bonus al Karp shovels
fat into your mitochondria for energy
you feel most of these things within 30
minutes to an hour okay I don't know
about this here I had a beer after a
week of that wasn't feeling it and
decided I'm not much of a fan anymore
or a fan of THC still smoke well yeah if
you're depressed though alcohol and weed
are depressed
boozing weed in video games is a source
of serotonin but in the same way coke is
not natural but the supplements I listed
are naturally occurring in your body
some of us are just deficient well I see
so these natural things that aren't in
your body I would just be worried you
know just considering that's not natural
in your body then you take it like what
that does to your liver or stuff like I
was getting nervous with the silicone
versions of that type of [ __ ] unless
you're - unless those don't sound like
all Naturals I don't know that there's a
finite Lala 9 tree out there that you're
eating leaves off of anyway anyway I
drink here and there honey moon etc but
I don't miss it I kind of I kind of miss
missing it that's exactly where I am but
anyway the supplements are cheap and
underrated as [ __ ] you're my favorite
comedian and decent dudes so I figured
I'd offer this to you talk talk all this
[ __ ] you want but try it first go [ __ ]
yourself you know what I respect the
fact that you're using this and it's
working for you I'm happy I hope there's
no side effects or anything like that
but uh yeah I'm not a I'm not a pill guy
I don't like taking that [ __ ] furthest I
go was like vitamins but I actually what
you're doing I get out of flying playing
drums hanging out with my kid working
out I try to you know going for a walk
doing a set getting a new laughs on it
you know on a new joke I can get it out
of that and you know I think towards the
end of this year when I was just
studying and studying studying and I
stopped playing drums I wasn't doing as
many sets and I felt like the depression
was starting to come on me again the fog
of it was like catching up to me so I
kind of did learn that so alright if
this works for you and there's no side
effects god bless you
so it's serotonin I don't know I I'm not
going to try to go through these [ __ ]
things alpha GPC or CDP coline for focus
and clearing brain fog
Jesus Christ I imagine I could use that
every once in a while anyway alright
dilemma a hey Billy bursitis oh that's a
great one
Billy bursitis oh my god this podcast as
long as [ __ ] how in twenty minutes I
gotta get out of here this one this one
is a little is a title contender this
guy's talking [ __ ] right out of the gate
would you rather get lit on fire a
hundred yards away from the nearest body
of water or get a [ __ ] from a
rattlesnake both are probably gonna kill
you and both are gonna hurt bad choose
wisely and go [ __ ] yourself that one's
easy I get the [ __ ] from a [ __ ]
rattlesnake without a doubt they have
anti-venom you know I take that the
[ __ ] bite marks on my dick go away
and then I'm fine I mean there's no cure
for [ __ ] being on fire for a hundred
yards and then I watched enough Richard
Pryor to know what that bath feels like
you know 100 yards yeah your fingers are
gonna melt off you're gonna lose your
ears your nose I am [ __ ] that that's an
easy one this one's a title contenders
sir you got to come harder than that you
know what it's the holiday season
dooby-dooby-doo I'm gonna give you a
second shot at that come up with a
better one that was a [ __ ] easy one
[ __ ] by a rattlesnake hands [ __ ]
down hands down you know any I live in a
major city that has rattlesnakes they're
gonna have anti-venom all that would
have to talk to my wife and tell her I
was getting a [ __ ] from a rattlesnake
and I'll have to live with the shame of
that I think that's what it more is I
would you I've just put it on some
Native American [ __ ] this was an
initiation into the Native American
tribe that was out here that we white
people attacked and eliminated and out
of respect for them I had spent it that
way you know deal with three days of
[ __ ] on social media and I would be
all right that's the podcast Merry
Christmas Happy Hanukkah happy Kwanzaa
to everybody thank you guys so much for
listening to the podcast coming out to
my shows it's been a great year it's
been an unbelievable decade and bigger
and better things are not even bigger
and better just [ __ ] continue a
living an awesome life in the next the
next decade all right don't be an
[ __ ] go [ __ ] yourselves enjoy your
holiday break that's it
I'm predicting Seattle well I'll
actually I'll be on the podcasts on
Thursday we'll talk to Seattle 49ers on
Thursday all right go [ __ ] yourself so
I'll see you